not entirely sure but hopefully the
audio is working and videos working to
just about to start a cyma wish everyone
look and we'll get going actually
someone just left he accepts that person
okay so six player Simon
[Music]
and I actually didn't realize that one
player is rated close to 2100 so playing
the Budapest against him is going to be
somewhat risky but okay we'll see how it
goes this is Grand Prix attack one of my
favorite openings and I'm gonna do a lot
of this without commentary but if we run
into like any interesting moments I will
try to explain myself d5 is usually not
a good move because it just gives me
some squares in the center
I'll see you Queenie - queenie - lets
play 96 and this is a very common idea
when the bishops are developed like this
usually if I can play c4 in Queen b3
it'll be pretty annoying for him to
defend c7 or to defend b7 I should say
Queen b3
and I'm looking at which there's only
one person watching I think I'm going to
go ahead and share the twitch stream
just want to make sure the boy looks
okay just give me one moment
okay you type in the chat by the way
extreme eating this on Twitch for anyone
interested okay so hopefully that works
and then hopefully we'll get viewers is
right now I'm the only one viewing this
and a few of the games are featuring
like very similar openings this should
be for check is slightly annoying see my
C 394 rook c1
I don't think I'm losing anything
okay actually I do have to be careful
here as if I play rook c1 he can play
Knight takes c3 B takes c3 and Bishop a3
oh but then I have a trick yeah
hopefully he's not watching the stream
and then falls into the trick but we'll
see see I like my leading developments
but I don't think I can punish him in
any way and I do see those four people
watching three of which are not me so if
you do want to leave a comment or
interact feel free I'll be checking the
bow B chest chat and also the twitch
chat as well okay let's go for this idea
with future plans with night f8 in 96
I really want to punish this guy for
just being slow in developing the e5
doesn't do anything I can't I can barely
make a threat here I'll just continue
developing it's like Queen B 3 Queen B 3
might be the move of the the cyma so far
okay this guy's not falling for the trap
immediately take it's very normal for
these types of Simon's where at least
the openings go smoothly but when I get
to middle games it becomes a lot easier
to blunder so have to be a little bit
cautious okay he fell into the chat so
clearly he's either not paying attention
or just overlooked Queen I for I guess
in an alternate universe Bishop a3 would
have won in the exchange but
unfortunately not in this case what to
do okay some maneuvering Knight b6 you
can play c4
yeah I don't think there's any game
where I'm terribly concerned yet but
that can very easily change with uh with
one move might be five is kind of
annoying let's just be safe Wow up to
seven viewers on Twitch I think this is
an all-time record for me for those who
don't know I started my twitch channel
yesterday and I've been doing like just
a few test streams but this is a
actually the first one that I've
publicly shared me chess and then the
goal is to eventually have this as one
of like the main streams which can
appear in the Lilly chess homepage but
we'll see if things go according to plan
this has been the most difficult game
for me so far so I feel like I should
have more but I think I just have to be
patient okay let's be aggressive
it's very tempting to play e5 but again
I'm just gonna be patience
something is slightly up with the
internet I think just the amount of
bandwidth I'm I'm using between twitch
and I'm playing six games at once this
is a free pot I'm a little bit curious
if if the viewer isn't which are the
ones playing the Simon it's currently
there's there's six viewers and twitch
and six games going on in Simoes I
wouldn't be surprised
which means I'll probably have to not
give away too many too many plans let's
get the bishop here oh I won one game
already now I guess which game was that
Oh as a game whoever blundered Queen a
for a check okay off to a good start
one down five to go
that looks like a free pawn I really
like my bishops b and b b7 they do some
long-distance damage
yeah so far no one's really giving me
any challenges okay let's stick with the
bishop
I think this game is still my toughest
game despite despite the fact it seems
like a good position but I don't see how
to break through ok let's play Queen C -
Queen C 297 hmm start with rook d8 oh
this is a guy who messaged me earlier so
he's putting up a good game then
afterwards we can certainly look at it
a bit more closely I'm gonna play Queen
c7 let's see what he's up to
by losing a piece here 9 F to do not
enough to
I guess I want another game somewhere
which is nice I should win this game
pretty shortly let's calculate and I
take G for King take G 3 Queen us 4
followed by 93 check when team Queen
okay so official takeout 390 got three I
don't think I get that much I could go
for at six f6 Bishop take T five I've
taken you five I think is just better
for black and if that's the case f6 say
Knight g6 queen h2 King f1 queen to h3 I
win at least upon I think this works
yeah with this line I think I just win I
should also just be winning upon I also
still have tricks with some queen h2
ideas actually I forgot about this game
this game is also relatively balanced so
far I didn't really get much out of out
of the opening I do like my position and
just slightly better pieces down two to
three viewers on Twitch could be because
that I guess I've already won four games
maybe the players who lost stop paying
attention for those who are watching if
you want to comment in the twitch chat
and let me know if you're the ones
playing the games that would be somewhat
helpful to me and if you're not playing
the games just feel free to interact ask
questions always happy to answer Bishop
c4 it's probably the best move because
if I take on d4 with a pawn he takes on
u6 if I take on d4 the Queen
you also take some u6 so what if I play
for its material here it's equal so a
position like this with opposite colored
bishops if we trade Queens it could be
very Josh but if we keep Queens on the
board it should favor the attacker which
i think is just me and if I play e4 I
mean this could just be a winning move
because there's so many weaknesses on
his King side and I will see what he
does after this it's by 95
so it's really just two games going one
of them I might win very quickly so this
this game might be the the one that
lasts the longest but it's nice and
Simon's when it starts out with a lot of
games and a bunch of them just finished
quickly I'll check my message here okay
nothing too eventful
and I really haven't been paying
attention to time but I think I think
I'm doing completely fine in both games
okay Brooke C - a couple moves I come to
mind Merc f3 as possible when h2 is
possible
something like Queen h2 king of one
Bishop to g3
I don't see anything clear and I do have
to watch out for time you might just
start with Queen h2
now actually I think I see a nice trick
after a king f1 I think rook f3 she
broke up three Bishop to e6 oh my gosh
be careful there I really want to play
knight c6
I don't think it doesn't even see for
just c4 Knight c7 hmm my five five this
should be seven I take on you six okay
let's do it okay so I was hoping for a
rook f3 and if you didn't have Bishop to
e6 I think it would be completely fine
but it's a six pawn is actually kind of
annoying to defend if I play Bishop g3 I
should take you six King h8 problem is
he has f2 defended so the safe option is
Queen h1 teeny - for got six I'll go for
that
I still still really want to play rogue
f3 but it doesn't work there's my four
wait Bishop f4 push I think e6 King h8
Queen c3 it's got to be good
III take III I don't see anything that
clear I never got sick special take you
six anyway
okay I'll go for this I mean it should
still be very good for black I have a
pretty big time advantage in this game
and he just blundered and I think with
96 I mean sometimes it's very easy to
miss like simple tactics like this when
you're switching back and forth between
games I was about to apply f10 key six
instantly there but I think good I think
it's going to come down to Varga being
the last game given that this guy is
about to flag I'm King h8 I'm Bishop t4
King h1 okay so I saw coming parallel
action there with Bishop Chuck and King
h8 king h1 and okay Varga just blundered
a queen makes my life easy let's take
this I have a very pleasant choice let's
take the rook
mmm let's take the pawn first okay yeah
a tough game Varga if you're watching
you put up a good fight I think the
opening was a little bit dubious but you
managed to still get a very playable
position and it came down to some
moments later where I think that you
just created too many weaknesses on the
kingside and maybe you underestimated
the danger of attack and maybe there are
some other moments you could have played
there's some stronger defensive moves
anyway I'm gonna finish this game and
then if anyone is around and wants to go
over stuff I'd be happy to do that so
this is just a matter of technique I
really want to play Queenie gates and I
take its Queen take or pawn take equals
Queen looks good
I kind of want to promote to a rook this
actually happened once in a tournament I
think goes Nakamura he promoted to a
night thinking that wouldn't change the
result of the game but then he ended up
losing but in this case it's nice to
have three rooks on the board okay well
thanks everyone for watching I think
there's only one player still or one
person still watching the stream when
you type in the chat thanks for the
games
everyone let's just say GG's everyone
and if no one responds and no one is
really watching or commenting on Twitch
I'm gonna end the stream I hope hope you
guys enjoyed it
I'll probably end up uploading this to
youtube so if anyone wants to go back at
some point I'll link my twitch and
YouTube together so they'll be easier to
find anyway I will see you guys in the
next stream adios